[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نحن هنا في Stoke Yard Outfitters
Sauna Village قادمون
إليها وهي واحدة من الأماكن الجديدة هنا في
مينيابوليس حيث يمكن للناس القدوم
والاستمتاع بتجربة ساونا عالية الجودة حقًا ،
لذلك لدينا غرفتا ساونا هنا أم غرف
الساونا لدينا لأنها
انطقها بالفنلندية ، فنحن قادرون حقًا على تقديم بعض الثقافة المحلية لجميع الأشخاص الذين يسافرون ، وكان هذا حقًا ما ألهمني بالسفر إلى مدن أخرى في مناخنا ، ومن أفضل الأشياء التي يجب القيام بها في هذه الأماكن هي الثقافة الحرارية المحلية الخاصة بهم
[  موسيقى]
مجتمع 612 sano هو جمعية تعاونية مملوكة للأعضاء
ونذهب إلى أماكن مختلفة
حول المدينتين التوأم التي كنا في
صالة ألعاب رياضية للتسلق أه مصانع الجعة آه نحن هنا
في حديقة ثيودورورث نحن ساونا عامة
كثيرًا  من الناس خائفون من
التفكير في أنك في أوروبا تذهب عارياً بشكل
تقليدي هنا ، لا ، ليس لدينا
بعض البدلات التي عادة ما يكون لدينا جمهور أصغر سنًا ،
وهناك الكثير من الرياضيين الذين
يحبون أن يأتي الكثير من الناس مثلي أنا
فقط أحب ذلك  تعال من أجل المتعة على ما
أعتقد  خاصة في الساعة 612 ، هناك
أشخاص لديهم تراث فنلندي من
التراث الاسكندنافي ، والكثير من الألمان
والأشخاص من روسيا ، والجميع
يجلب نوعًا من تقاليد الساونا الخاصة بهم ،
وهناك نوع من
حركة الساونا في أقصى الشمال والتي
تتغير باستمرار ومثيرة
حقًا لقد تزوجت  سبتمبر الماضي
وحجزنا بالفعل غرفة في فندق إنساني
في وسط مدينة مينيابوليس
ولديهم ساونا جميلة على السطح
ذهبنا بالفعل والتقطنا صورتنا
في ثوب زفافي وكان
يرتدي بدلة توكس
في الساونا
[موسيقى]
نقوم بالبرمجة هنا  على مدار
الأسبوع ، نقدم تجارب مختلفة للاستحمام الحراري
من جميع
أنحاء العالم
هنا إلى هذا السطح الجميل الذي يحتوي
على ساونا تطل على وسط مدينة
مينيابوليس وهي ساونا كبيرة جدًا ،
لذا يمكننا القيام ببعض
البرامج الخاصة هنا والتي تشمل
بخار الساونا الموجهة.  العلاج العطري الذي يعتمد
على تقاليد المكتب الألماني
الليلة سيبدأ الناس في
الجلسة الإرشادية داخل  ساونا ، سنقوم بثلاث
جولات بالزيوت
الأساسية ونقوم بتوصيل البخار في جميع أنحاء الغرفة
بالمنشفة ثم نخرج في
مكان بارد لدينا يغطس
بارد ويمكن للناس أن يبردوا هنا في
الهواء الليلي لدينا عدة
مواقع مختلفة  والتجارب المختلفة
المتاحة في جميع أنحاء المدينة ، يمكنك حقًا أن
تجد ما تحتاجه ، تعال إلى
مينيابوليس واستمتع ببعض الثقافة الحرارية